اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مخيم النصيرات
وسط قطاع غزه اهلا بكم كتائب القسام تنشر
تسجيلا تقول انه لثلاث محتجزات لديها في
قطاع غزه ويتضمن الشريط رسائل من
المحتجزات الى نتنياهو وحكومته يطالبن
فيها باطلاق سراحهن على الفور ويتحدثن عن
فشل سياسي وامني وعسكري اسرائيل تقول انها
تنفذ هجوما بالمدرعات في غزه وتخوض كات مع
مسلحين فلسطينيين وكتائب القسام تعلن انها
استهدفت اليتين اسرائيليتين توغلت في حي
الزيتون ودبابات في شارع صلاح الدين شرقي
القطع ومصادر طبيه فلسطينيه تقول ان ثلاثه
مدنيين استشهدوا جراء استهداف سيارتهم
خلال توغل اليات الاحتلال بشارع صلاح
الدين وسط غارات اسرائيليه متواصله على
قطاع غزه السلطات الصحيه في غزه تقول ان
عدد الشهداء ارتفع الى
8306 وتناشد مصر فتح معبر رفح للسماح
بدخول المساعدات الطبيه وخروج الجرحى في
حين تقول منظمه انقذ الاطفال ان 40% ممن
قتلوا في غزه من الاطفال واذاعه جيش
الاحتلال تتحدث عن اصابات في مبنى ومصنع
بعسقلان جراء صواريخ اطلقت من غزه اربعه
شهداء بنيران قوات الاحتلال خلال اقتحامها
مدينه جنين ومخيمها وكتيبه جنين في سرايا
القدس تؤكد فشل العمليه العسكريه ووزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه تقول ان
121 شهيدا سقطوا في الضفه الغربيه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر الى
اللقاء